[Musique]
pierre connais ça bonjour bonjour nous
vous interrogeons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne youtube qui s'appelle thinker
view on aurait aimé avoir un peu votre
point de vue sur les récents événements
qu est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
petit petit point biographiques et puis
petit point de retour en arrière bon moi
j'ai travaillé une vingtaine d'années
dans les eaux ministère de la défense
français sur différentes domaines qui va
quel poste tout sauf de l'administration
c'est à dire affaires stratégiques
exportations d'armements renseignement
puis d'une manière générale réflexion
sur l'organisation du ministère
post que j'ai quitté au début des années
2000 pour diriger une société
d'intelligence économique pendant
environ huit ans
maintenant ça va je suis retraité
heureux parce que je peux faire ce que
j'ai envie de faire c'est à dire en fait
écrire je suis libéré de la parole si
vous voulez moi alors premier premier
aspect extrêmement important qui va
peut-être expliquer plus précisément mon
mode de réflexion
j'étais donc sur les affaires
stratégiques dans les annes la décennie
90 décennie 90 c'est le moment où l'urss
tous fait la mauvaise blague disparaitra
c'est ce que dit le conseil est de
gorbatchev au sommet d'helsinki à
type de l équipe de
américaine on va vous faire l'amour
entre deux pires des services on vous
priver l'ennemi alors sa part une blague
mais en fait dans le système de
réflexion stratégique c'est évidemment
un traumatisme parce que comment
voulez-vous réfléchir aux risques aux
menaces ou au défi quand vous n'avez
plus d'ennemis c'est à dire soit vous
avez le chômage technique donc vous
licenciez puis vous pensez que les
budgets vont diminuer soit vous créez de
la nuit qu'est ce que vous entendez par
créer de la cré leurs visées c'est ce
que tout le monde a vu barrette dans les
années 90 c'est à dire une réflexion
américaine consistant à dire consistant
en particulier à diffuser de la pensée
comme par exemple le chat bleu le choc
des civilisations comme par exemple le
bouquin huntington ou comme par exemple
la fin de la fin de l'histoire la
boucane fukuyama chaque fois ces
thématiques sur lesquelles je reviendrai
était
amplifié reprise et diffusée par tous
les médias de tous les pays pour vous de
prendre un exemple le bouquin ultime
tonnes a été traduit en 35 langues
or y poser une problématique sur
laquelle on pouvait avoir des une
distance critique extrêmement importante
puisque sa supposée qu'il ya une espèce
de monde arabo islamique était par
nature agressif et c'était évidemment le
point de vue américain au dessus mais à
partir du moment où le bouquin été
diffusés comme la nouvelle pensée
américaine ça formaté tout le débat
c'est à dire qu'on ne pouvait que se
positionner pour ou contre le boucanier
tiquetonne bon je prends un autre et
vous êtes avec nous soit vous êtes
contre nous oui c'est ça alors ce qui
est rigolo c'est que bush quand ils
utilisent la phrase il transforme la
phrase de la bible c'est à dire que la
phrase de la bible c'est tout ce qu'ils
ne sont pas contre nous sont avec nous
la phrase de bush s'étaient tous ceux
qui sont pas avec nous sont contre nous
c'est rigolo comme changement sémantique
c'est à dire que il reprenait la phrase
de la bible dans la forme la plus
exclusive et celles qui étaient le plus
de nature à créer du conflit
bon et donc le set autre exemple qu'ils
veulent et qui est fascinant c'est
l'exemple du bouquin de fukuyama qui va
être un des soutiens de bush en irak qui
va favoriser qui va soutenir l'agression
américaine en irak sa thèse était
simplement la fin de l'histoire le
modèle démocratique libéral va être riom
fait donc finalement une certaine
manière il y a plus d'histoire vous avez
eu le succès de la thèse on peut pas
dire que ce soit effectivement une
vision prospective qui s'est traduite
dans la réalité mais ce qui m'a
intéressé beaucoup plus c'était la façon
dont à chaque fois par ici un book
américain vous avez une espèce de
mobilisation de tous les journaux les
quotidiens les news à chaque fois
faisant des interviews des débats et sur
les cessions ou une propagande moi je
donne je laisse la vienne comment dire
le je considère que les médias sont
libres de leurs choix éditoriaux et donc
que je les prends pas pour des
auxiliaires de justice c'est pas leur
sujet ils essayent de fait de surfer sur
ce qu'est l'actualité comment se crée
l'actualité après ça c'est une autre
question mais d'une manière générale
appartement vous avez un sujet qui fait
le buzz vous avez immédiatement
reprise par les médias
donc ce qui m'a beaucoup plus intéressé
c'est finalement comment fonctionne ce
mécanisme de production stratégique
alors on est tous habitués à par exemple
a parlé du complexe militaro industriel
us mi-temps ministre aime ça veut dire
actions des militaires avec les
industriels défense qui seraient les
faiseurs de guerre or moi j'étais au
ministère de la défense est ce que je
constate c'est que les militaires
étaient pas du tout belliciste d'abord
parce qu'ils savent ce que c'est que la
guerre c'est voler et que par contre
fonctionner un espèce de complexe
militaro intellectuelle composé en
particulier des think tanks qui
produisait ses fameux bouquin d'un
certain nombre d'intellectuels
médiatiques
de
services académiques et puis évidemment
à l'intérieur des ministères de systèmes
de réflexion stratégique j'ouvre une
parenthèse qu'au sein de ces
institutions vous avez vu une
conjonction de personnes ayant été formé
aux états unis où ils ont une doctrine
américaine pas à ce moment-là pas à ce
moment là on était plutôt si vous venez
dans une relève générationnelle c'est à
dire par exemple les soviétologue était
déjà en perte de vitesse puisque y avait
plus de sauvignon soviétique et cela se
battaient désespérément pour garder si
vous voulez dans leur espace
administratif par exemple les anciens
pays de l'urss devenu indépendant gros
débat administrative c est ce que les
pays d'asie centrale nouvellement
indépendants doivent relever du monde
turc ou persan langue qui parlait ou au
contraire relevé de l'ex urss parce
qu'ils étaient anciens pays soviétiques
voyez par exemple donc c'était rigolo
parce que c'était une espèce de querelle
d'expertisé mais qui était en fait un
enjeu de pouvoir comment est-ce que je
reste conseiller du prince non la relève
générationnelle est arrivé plus tard en
particulier c'est celle qui est au
pouvoir aujourd'hui c'est à dire de gens
qui ont eu cette espèce de fascination
de la puissance américaine parce que la
décennie 90 c'est la décennie de
l'hyperpuissance de l'unilatéralisme
il ya plus de rival cohérent
réellement stratégique allure l alliance
aux états unis et donc à ce moment là
une espèce de fascination sur comment va
faire le leader majoritaire comment
est-ce qu'on va le suivre quelle
position adopter vis-à-vis de lui et c
est la dernière survivante gaullienne si
vous voulez de la diplomatie française
c'est la réaction de chirac refusant
d'aller en irak après ça si vous voulez
tout le reste est balayée sarkozy
hollande etc tout ça devient une espèce
de génération des néoconservateurs en
partie formé aux états unis ou en tout
cas ayant une fascination pour les états
unis et qui vont suivre plus même encore
que les britanniques si vous voulez les
américains à peu près partout dans le
monde peut-être un petit bout sur les
âmes et un camion je te montre trop
écouter c'est ce qui est très étonnant
c'est que c'est complètement intériorisé
comme des études c'est à dire qu'il ya
plus aucune distanciation critique ils
vont pas dire j'ai été formé par le csa
et s où j'ai été formé par fait non pas
du tout c'est une espèce de comment dire
c'est presse des compagnons de route si
vous voulez comme on le disait à
l'époque de l'urss c'est des gens qui
gardent leur liberté d'esprit qui ont
leur liberté d'expression mais qui sont
totalement américaine m'a aidé
aujourd'hui
et on le on le constate par exemple sur
la politique à l'égard de l'iran qui
devient totalement incompréhensible
c'est à dire comme ils n'ont pas vu le
virage américain ils vont être obligés
de rétropédaler si vous voulez pour se
dire mais après tout maintenant on a
besoin de l'iran pour résoudre la crise
irakienne pour réseaux d'afghanistan
pour résoudre la crise au liban et
c'était en syrie donc on est dans une
situation où si vous voulez m la
génération qui est actuellement celle
des stratégistes est une génération qui
est justement totalement décalé par
rapport à la réalité
alors comment se passe le phénomène
s'est passé intéressant parce que par
exemple dans les années 90 on était donc
dans la crise en yougoslavie la crise
yougoslavie était effectivement une
crise qui nous concernait directement à
cause de la disposition continental à
cause du fait que c'était quand même sur
le territoire européen un des pays
occupés par l'allemagne qui avaient le
plus souffert de l'occupation allemande
qui avait eu les camps de concentration
et auront retrouvé en yougoslavie un
certain nombre de comportements les
camps de concentration au serbe sera
fermée les croates les viols collectifs
enfin on avait tous donc ça concernait
directement les européens et les
européens à l'époque pensaient que une
alliance franco anglaise suffiraient à
calmer tout le monde à ce moment là on a
découvert que ça suffisait même pas
dissuader les serbes de faire ce qu'ils
avaient à faire bon donc là on s'est
rendu compte de la faiblesse à l'égard
des américains enfin plutôt à l'égard de
même d'une puissance moyenne comme la
serbie et donc de la nécessité d'avoir
un appui américain c'était l'époque où
les américains n'étaient pas
spécialement une belle ici c'est à dire
que l'époque clinton était une époque où
il a fallu le tirer par la manche pour
qu'ils viennent s'était pas il
considérait que c'était une autre
affaire mais on était aussi dans un
moment où crise économique aidant si
vous voulez tout le monde réduisez ce
budget de défense tout le monde était un
peu réticent les allemands en
particulier intervenir militairement et
c'est ça donc il ya aussi ce choc là
c'est à dire le fait que si on n'est
même pas capable de gérer une crise
européenne du niveau de la crise
yougoslave c'est que véritablement on a
deux options possibles soit on fait une
europe de la défense mais ça devient
débat philosophique à peu près comme le
sexe des anges ou alors on se met dans
le sillage américain et ça c'est
l'option qui s'est fait de manière
inconsciente et sur laquelle on a
ensuite continuellement décliner donc
l'italie jeunes saint française où
l'intelligentsia parisienne
à pousser pour aller dans ce sens là
c'est à dire c'est c'est le
misérabilisme d'impuissance libéralisme
intellectuelle c'est là le fait de ne
pas vouloir se soustraire du groupe pro
us je crois que non il ya eu plusieurs
choses d'abord il ya la confrontation à
la réalité
constater qu'on n'était pas capable de
gérer en tant qu'européens une crise
comme la yougoslavie c'est quand même un
constat dramatique ça voulait dire que
sur le territoire européen on n'était
même pas capable militairement d'avoir
une force d'interposition qu'ils ont
suffisamment dissuasives n'oubliez pas
quand même que le siège de sarajevo a
duré mille jours comme le siège de
leningrad quand même bon en d'autres
temps évidemment déjà ce constat est
terrible 2500 frappe aérienne alors
ensuite il y avait effectivement
comment dire cette espèce de gestion de
la force qui faisait qu'on voulait pas
s'engager dans une guerre on voulait en
même temps avoir une action suffisamment
dissuasives pour que les serbes soit
n'aillent pas trop loin mais en même
temps rappelez vous on a laissé faire
gorazde on a laissé faire des
occupations avec parfois des massacres
le tout étant évidemment une crise de la
conscience européenne puisque encore une
fois c'était un constat d'impuissance je
reviens vous puisque vous parlez de
l'ex yougoslavie qu'est ce que vous
pensez
des charniers de timisoara
et ça c'est plutôt une question qui
concerne les journalistes c'est à dire
que quand on est dans une situation de
tension médiatique comme par exemple les
jours qu'on a vécu semaine dernière il
est évident qu'il ya une comment dire
une surproduction de l'information
j'étais invité sur le plateau d'europe
je crois que c'était jeudi ou vendredi
dernier en fin quand il y avait là les
forces de police et de gendarmerie ont
décidé d'attaquer les deux les deux
endroits tenus par les aime
parler et eros
c'était extraordinaire parce que d'abord
le type de radio commenté des images de
télévision
ensuite il demandait à ses spécialistes
journalistes de commenter les ou un truc
de télévision et puis comme il fallait
entretenir une espèce de tension
médiatique il passait la parole un coup
aux correspondants qui se trouvait à
bastia l'un aux correspondants qui se
trouvaient en bas dans mary et alors les
types ils n'avaient pas grand chose à
dire donc celui d'un mari disait ben oui
il ya deux hélicoptères qui survolent
n'ont peut-être trois et on en voyait
peut-être de bon ça c'est exemple le
mans de l'information qui était une
information de la tension mais qui en
fait n'a porté et vincennes c'était
encore plus caricaturale puisque le type
de vincennes disait ben on a contact
avec la voisine qui est au dessus de
l'hypermarché la dame disait ben écoutez
moi je n'ai rien à vous dire parce que
d'abord mes fenêtres donnent de l'autre
côté puis ensuite les policiers m'ont
demandé de passer de fermer les fenêtres
ensuite il interrogé le pompiste qui
habitait en face de l'hypermarché le
pompier disait mais moi je viens vous
dire je le naufrage du journalisme on
note bien avec l'émergence d'internet
la question je me pose c'est où est ce
couvent c'est à dire on a une
augmentation des menaces les signaux
faibles sont au rouge on a
avec des capitaines de pédalos au sein
des cellules stratégique et prospective
on s'engage nous européens dans des
conflits libyen dans les confits syrien
et on se retrouve ensuite avec la bouche
en coeur on se prend des
répercussions des attaques terroristes
sur le sol français donc vous êtes en
train de me dire que l'on n'est pas
capable de gérer le kosovo qu'on
s'engage sur des guerres
où l'enlisement était prévisible et on
appuie l'argent oui le ce qui m'a
beaucoup intéressée notamment dans la
fabrication de la nuit c'est que je me
suis dit finalement quelle période
ouvres ton après 80 ans puisque
finalement n'ayant plus d'ennemis
pourquoi y at il encore des conflits et
je trouve que d'abord la déclaration de
bush qui a suivi le 11-septembre est
extrêmement intéressante parce que pour
la première fois les gars il déclare la
guerre à des concepts la guerre contre
la prolifération contre le terrorisme
qui sont encore une fois pas des ennemis
qui sont des concepts ils auraient au
sens spin doctor je crois que si vous
voulez il formate la domination
américaine sur le monde c'est à dire je
vous donne l'agenda je vous dis qu'il
faut se battre contre le terrorisme
international c'est lui qui a inventé ce
concept et puis il fait sur tours de
passe-passe stratégie de formidable dans
lequel il dit la prolifération la menace
principale
alors qu'il ya 11 saoudiens sur 15
membres de la taille de l'avion
septembre sur le site iraq et il dit que
les églises axe du mal c'est l'irak
l'iran et la corée du nord l'arabie
saoudite personne n'en parle donc c'est
ça qui est intéressant c'est à dire
comment est ce qu'on va concevoir un
ennemi dans lequel on va formater le
camp occidental en l'espèce mans et
immédiatement la déclinaison vous la
connaissez invasion de l'afghanistan
on peut aujourd'hui dresser le bilan et
puis immédiatement dans la foulée l'irak
première fracture alors l'afghanistan
est intéressant parce que
pour peu qu'on ait un minimum de
connaissances historiques tout le monde
s'est cassé les dents sur l'afghanistan
qui est formidable les anglais à la
belle époque du colonialisme l'once
alors les anglais ils arrivent jusqu'à
kaboul et puis finalement voyant qu'ils
peuvent pas tenir le pays ils incendient
le bazar de kaboul de plus de bazar à
kaboul aujourd'hui c'est quand même
fantastique faut le savoir et puis dans
le repli ils sont pris par une attaque
lac albert passe ou et exterminer la
totalité du corps expéditionnaire
britannique sauf un ils ont les afghans
sauf un type pour qu'il aille raconter
aux autres qui s'est passé non mais
justement et c'est la première fois
qu'ils s'étaient créées elles étaient
pas créé par la fois la puissance
stratégique dominante elle été créée par
une bonne de va-nu-pieds qui étaient les
avants de l'époque les soviétiques dix
ans sur place le résultat vous le
connaissez
quatre millions de réfugiés au pakistan
deux millions de réfugiés en iran et
finalement ils quittent l'afghanistan
et ne tenant absolument pas compte de ça
je suis à peu près certain que le monde
qui l'entouré bush au monde la décision
était des gens qui n'ayant jamais mis le
pied de toute façon en afghanistan
diemer l'aghanistan offert notre affaire
tout de suite on va attraper ben laden
on va renverser le mollah omar et vous
allez voir les taliban pour une balle y
est c'est vrai que les talibans ont été
balayés le problème c'est qu'il n'était
pas au courant que la guerre était finie
vous avez c'est comme la déclaration de
georges bush quand y'a l'invasion en
irak la première phase de façon
conventionnelle le régime l'armée de
saddam hussein est balayé et puis george
bush je fais ce fantastique discours sur
le porte-avions en disant c'est bon on a
gagné bon problème c'est que les autres
sont pas n'étaient pas informés que la
guerre n'était pas finie et ils ont
continué et donc on est aujourd'hui en
deuil nos pour reprendre le cas de
l'afghanistan après un bilan qui est
particulièrement catastrophique puisque
ça fait 13 ans sur place le même effort
de défense que les soviétiques civile il
ya 6000 milliards si on compte la
totalité c'est un point sur lequel on
pourra revenir si vous voulez c'est à
dire la totalité c'est avait compris le
coût des blessés le coût des indemnités
le coût des vols similaires je compte
pas les vétérans et
autres aspects stratégiques importants
l'extension de la guerre au pakistan
parce que les soviétiques cédait
toujours interdit de franchir la
frontière tandis que les frappes de
drones frappent sur le territoire les
zones tribales et donc l'extension
derrière bilan de tout ça vous le
connaissez c'est à dire un retour
probable des talibans alors le régime
najib ou là qui avait succédé au 108 104
pages toutes parts dont vous parlez pas
ce non pas du tout pas du tout et donc
le si et comment dire le agile vous là
que les russes laissent en place après
leur départ tient deux ans on peut
prendre le pari de savoir première va
tenir le régime afghan aujourd'hui
bilan catastrophique
par pitié et dames et par grandeur d'âme
je n'insisterai pas sur l' opération
française en libye
mais c'est exactement dans cette
situation là on va revenir sur l'ebit
puisque vous évoquez bien shell oui
bernard henri lévy
bombardé
pratiquement mise des affaires
étrangères
au côté de john mccain
sur 7 sur certaines photos ne voit pas
sur certaines photos mais en compagnie
de john mccain sur le territoire qu'est
ce que vous en pensez alors qu'est ce
que c'est que voulait le je vous ai
parlé de la génération enfin delà du
concept de guerre qui était la guerre
contre les concepts ça c'était le
producteur américain mais aujourd'hui
locaux on est obligé de faire le constat
qu'il n'y a pas de menace stratégique
le terrorisme n'a jamais permis de
gagner une guerre
donc même le terrorisme si c'est grave
si ça me tue des gens etc ça reste que
ce n'est pas une menace stratégique de
l'ampleur de ce qu'était l'armée rouge
dans les années de 50 à 2000 morts donc
on est aujourd'hui dans une époque où si
on regarde l'ensemble des conflits qui
dirait déchirent la planète y en a à peu
près 400 mais comment fait-on ce choix
pour dire celui-là est grave cela n'est
pas grave conomique pas seulement pas
seulement parce que justement vous avez
cette catégorie de gens qui sont les
intellectuels médiatiques il ya des
nouveaux si vous voulez faiseurs
d'opinion en matière stratégique les
premiers c'est les intellectuels
médiatiques dans la catégorie dans
laquelle entre bhl premier point mais il
ya aussi les humanitaires qui vous dit
je connais les victimes donc je connais
les bourgs et puis vous avez les
diasporas qui vont vous dire au nom de
la souffrance que j'ai subie à 50 ans je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi notre pays
doit s'engager vers telle ou telle
catégorie
exemple si vous voulez de diaspora sa
diaspora arménienne qui a réussi à faire
voter cette loi stupide qui fait que la
france reconnaît le génocide dans lequel
elle n'a strictement peut participer
r pour aller dé donner de leçons aux
autres mais est-ce qu'on va voter une
loi sur le génocide des indiens par
exemple il en est pas question est-ce
que les algérie va voter une loi sur les
jeunes aussi les combattants du fln pour
la france n'en est pas question donc
voyez cette habitude de gens qui vont
vous dire la france doit absolument
reconnaître que fait qu'il ya une force
de pression la victimologie d'un levier
important si vous voulez pour déterminer
les axes de la politique étrangère donc
si mes cc3 faiseurs d'opinion là qui
m'ont intéressé parce que cela il
s'adresse directement politique il passe
pas par des analyses disant
invention le concept le plus
extraordinaire qu'on avait intéressé a
récemment bon vous souvenez l'ingérence
humanitaire en somalie
l'ingérence humanitaire c'était les
chefs de guerre pis l'aide
internationale à la somalie aux pauvres
gens de somalie et donc il faut
absolument faire un effort de défense
pour rétablir
un pouvoir central qui allait enfin
gérer l'aide aux populations
plusieurs erreurs d'abord la stratégie
de l'émoi
parce que finalement
on a vu que je suis je prends à distance
ils veulent aujourd'hui tout le monde se
fout de ce qui se passe en somalie donc
il y avait bien un moment médiatique qui
avait suscité de l'émoi qui a appelé le
politique à faire quelque chose suisse
en général c'est le petit enfant maigre
qui tend la main pour avoir un peu de
riz ça peut être ça alors vous avez
différentes stratégies de la violer
les enfants sur le bas et c'est donc ça
c'est le canal médiatique par lequel ça
passe mais en même temps vous avez là
dessus les intellectuels médiatiques qui
vont vous dire nous ne pouvons pas ne
pas la double négation qui va expliquer
qu'il faut absolument y aller et donc on
invente avec kouchner et bettati l'idée
l'ingérence humanitaire alors pourquoi
l'ingérence humanitaire c'est très
intéressant parce que les humanitaires
avaient le vent en poupe a le vent en
poupe depuis les années 60 depuis le
biafra c'était le type d'action
internationale non étatiques dans
laquelle tout le monde se reconnaissait
donc il ya un capital politique qu'il
fallait absolument récupérer et donc on
a inventé le concept d' ingérence
humanitaire c'est à dire associé du
militaire à l'humanitaire donc le
concept de bombardements humanitaires
cessa pas seulement de bombardements
c'est à dire qu'il faut équipe faut
agrandir associer les convois
humanitaires à des forces armées donc
c'est ce que les mini humanitaires ont
toujours des lancers en disant mais non
nous scud man notre sécurité c'est de ne
pas être armé c'est d'apparaître comme
non belligérants est donc cette miction
qui a été principalement initiée par
kouchner s'était nous allons militarisé
l'action humanitaire le reste vous le
connaissez aujourd'hui c'est que les
humanitaires sont devenus des cibles par
la force des choses puisque plus
personne ne peut les considérer comme
indépendants alors pour avoir à écouter
certains certaines personnes un peu
barbu qui se s'en prennent aux convois
humanitaires ils me disent là on s'en
prend à eux parce que il ya de gros
suspicion d'injection de services de
renseignement ou simple ses oeuvres
humanitaires
c'est pour voir et c'est petit c'est
possible c'est peut-être vrai pas vrai
je ne sais pas mais du coup le seul fait
que la suspicion existe de même que sur
les journalistes la même suspicion
justifie le même type de comportement
d'hostilité et donc là où les
humanitaires se protéger justement par
leur pacifisme affiché à ce moment là
effectivement se poser la question de
savoir quel va être le comportement des
belligérants tu mens mais le
bouleversement fondamental c'est ce
concept d'ingérence humanitaire qui va
se traduire en somalie par le fait que
vous allez avoir des troupes américaines
qui vont débarquer en somalie en pleine
nuit sous les flashs et sous l'espagne
de sunlight des journalistes de
télévision c'est à dire les mecs rampe
par terre avec le visage tout noir et en
même temps ils sont auto il ya autour
d'eux des journalistes qu'il est filmé
en direct pour qu'aux états unis on
sache que les gi's arrive
pardon une mise en scène formidable with
mise en scène fort bien depuis
totalement contradictoires sur le plan
militaire donc on était dans quelque
chose qui évidemment à un moment ou à un
autre finir fr clasher deuxième aspect
qui me paraît très intéressant c'est
l'absence d' analyses politiques sur la
crise qu'on va retrouver en libye qu'on
va retrouver à cirer pourquoi parce que
l'analyse politique suppose qu'on fasse
un minimum de retour en arrière avant de
décider or le tempo médiatique n'est pas
le tempo stratégique si vous un
politique est interpellé vous ne pouvez
pas ne pas par un intellectuel
médiatique par des humanitaires etc eelv
a décidé dans l'urgence
alors pourquoi je vais insiste sur la
somalie face au mali c'est l'afghanistan
c'est le pays qui a résisté aux
colonisations exactement de la même
manière des structures tribales tout le
monde est armé et donc la sécurité est
assurée par votre tribu et donc le
colonisateur qui arrivent il peut être
soit l'allier soit l'ennemi mais en tout
état de cause les alliances se marie il
y avait un chef de guerre afghan qui dit
une phrase que je trouve toujours
merveilleuse qui disait on ne peut pas
acheter un chef de guerre afghan mais on
peut le louer
ce qui est formidable comme phrase ça
veut dire que vous êtes dans un système
d'alliances où chaque jour se négocie
vos alliés aux années somalie pareil
donc pourquoi le cas de la somalie et
être utile caricatural ce pays qui a été
reconstituée dans les années 50 par
jonction de la somalie italienne de la
somalie britannique est un pays donc où
l'eau que dans lequel immédiatement il
ya eu un coup d'état militaire ci est
barrée et si elle va réagir et 50 ans la
somalie en utilisant tous les moyens de
la force publique pour réprimer les
identités ethniques ça veut dire que
pour les somaliens qui avaient réussi à
se débarrasser de siad barré leur seul
objectif c'était surtout pas d'état
central parce que si vous mettez un état
central ça veut dire qu'il aura les
moyens de la force et donc il va avoir
le même type de comportement que si
elles varient et donc nous on arrivait
en chevalier blanc en disant pourquoi
vous aider à reconstituer un état
central les types se sont dit voyez un
peu toujours un peu de pognon à tirer
donc on va aller à la conférence d'addis
abeba des fondamentalement leur logique
propre c'était comment est-ce que je
reste moi indépendant dans mon espace
politique et ça pose une question grave
c'est que il peut y avoir des
territoires de la plaine dans lequel n'y
a pas d'état central alors et donc voyez
cet obstacle politique qui fait qu' on
ne sait plus faire dans ce cas là je
vais faire en parallèle avec la libye
la libye on va dire si cette tribu
qui avait été filé réparé kadhafi après
son coup d'état
kadhafi tombe le pouvoir se décentralise
les chefs de guerre locaux veulent avoir
accès aux ressources qui a sous leurs
pieds
on est là bas
ça
commence à un peu agacé les
ressortissants ayant dûment les
ressortissants ayant des accointances ou
et ils on
va dire une vision respectueuse de
l'islam voit des gamins se faire
bombarder sous de faux prétextes
ce qu'on valait en libye à la barre et
sauver la veuve et l'orphelin de grandir
on la guerre pour la belle la guerre
pour la peine ce grand concept on est là
bas maintenant la syrie
les gamins issus des banlieues avec un
pied entre deux continents
regarde la chose de façon dubitative
sauf que cette génération est connecté
sur internet et aussi est influencé par
internet il trouve aussi
les gants sont journalistique un peu
difficile à avaler
là on vient de recevoir des frappes sur
notre territoire
on comprend bien que depuis les 30
dernières années la géopolitique de
salon commence à avoir des répercussions
sur le terrain les militaires qui
connaissent les opex connaissent le prix
du sang neuf et les citoyens français
maintenant on commence à voir le prix du
sang sur leur terrain on fait quoi
d'abord on s'arrête on réfléchit comme
disait gbèdan fait quand même toujours
utile
ce qui n'est pas l'ambiance du moment
l'ambiance du moment c'est pour avoir
participé à certains de plateaux de
télévision les hommes politiques qui
viennent prendre acte
des déclarations qu'ils vont faire
maintenant pour pouvoir dire dans six
mois je l'avais dit alors la thématique
c'est il faut augmenter les budgets des
services de renseignement de la police
l'armée et ses toutes choses que je ne
discute pas mais c'est pas ça que
j'appelle s'arrêter on réfléchit
s'arrêter en réfléchit c'est de savoir
quelle est l'articulation entre
politique extérieure problèmes
d'intégration rapport avec la communauté
musulmane et ses ouailles est ce que
c'est ça qui à mon avis est la véritable
moyen de la réflexion et un sourire
coûte moins cher qu'une bonne c'est ça
c'est pas seulement ça c'est aussi le
fait que bien évidemment le passage à
l'acte violent est il légitime bien
évidemment le fait de choisir des cibles
juives en soi est inadmissible mais
qu'est-ce qu'il traduit et c'est ça qui
est la vérité ce n'est pas une question
ou c'est une question que vous posez non
je me pose la question à moi-même et
interpelle les politiques français si
vous voulez c'est à dire qu'est ce que à
ce moment là il faut savoir qu est-ce
qui ont la thématique psychiatrique si
vous voulez sur le thème ils sont fous
etc c'est pas mon problème non mais vous
voyez ses envies un moment il faut
s'interroger sur le rapport que la
société française a généré chez ces
jeunes voilà oui alors là on va élargir
un petit peu lol le fait de qualifier
les terroristes ayant une pathologie
psychiatrique
je trouve que c'est quand même fort de
café ou vue de l'opération qui a été
montée c'est à dire que vous avez en
face de vous des gens extrêmement bien
préparées extrêmement armés lourdement
armés qui pratique on va prendre le cas
de l'hyper cacher de vincennes porte de
vincennes
c'est la même technique d'intimidation
que les attentats sur les places de
marchés en irak c'est à dire jour de
marché les gens viennent
s'approvisionner parce que c'est jour de
marché il n'ya pas d'hypermarchés à bas
et ils frappent les jours de marché pour
terroriser la population vincennes saint
mandé et la zone c est une zone juive
dumora forte communauté juive où tout le
monde vit on attend de connaître la
nature tilala on voit des politiques
d'hier ce sont des malades au lieu
d'avoir une perception qui est beaucoup
plus structurée en disant voilà nous
avons fait des erreurs les gens en face
se sont organisés et va le frapper avec
la psychose que notre propre violence a
généré chaise ou parce que le fait
d'avoir quelques caricatures avec des
fous cinglés qui viennent là des gens
par contre je reviens sur votre point de
vue quel et l'introspection des forces
de renseignement face à des politiques
va-t-en-guerre hyper sécuritaire
non moi j'adhère pas à votre question
parce que c'est pas aux services de
renseignement de s'interroger sur le
poster des politiques eux ils ont un
mandat il a une mission on va leur
donner si vous voulez un plan de
renseignements la question sert comment
est-ce qu'il faut interpeller les
politiques pour qu'ils se livrent à ce
travail que vous évoquez c'est eux qui
ont le véritable pouvoir alors on peut
jouer son rôle en tant qu'intellectuel
on peut jouer son rôle entre
collaborateurs des services
administratifs etc mais il est évident
que il ya une part du langage qui est
bribes et quand on est à l'intérieur de
l'administration n'est pas dire à votre
ministre excusez moi monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères mais il
ya un certain nombre de thématiques
d'intervention sur lesquels il faut
revenir personne n'a fait le
officiellement regretté l'intervention
militaire en libye par rappelez vous
c'était plus beaux jours du monde du
président hoover du précédent président
et puis le mali c'est devenu le problème
plus beaux jours du monde de l'actuel
président donc on a une espèce de
triomphalisme dès que ça touche aux
militaires qui obturent si vous voulez
l'esprit c'est ce qui nous est arrivé
après 1918 on avait la meilleure armée
du monde vous connaissez la suite de
l'histoire donc ce type de réflexe il
faut le comprendre c'est à dire faut se
mettre dans la tête des gens n'y a pas
toujours le délai de la réflexion alors
pour revenir à votre question c'est
effectivement aujourd'hui pourquoi y at
il eu cette espèce de viscosité
vis-à-vis de la mobilisation collective
sur la liberté d'expression sur la
défense de charlie et c est pourquoi il
ya évidemment eu ces terrorisme
moi j'ai été à la suite d'une
conversation avec valse milices de
l'intérieur je faisais remarquer que
c'était étonnant qu'ils aient pas de
politique de contre projet contre
radicalisation en france qu'est ce que
j'entendais par là
j'entendais par la queue on avait des
problèmes avec une certaine partie de la
communauté musulmane mais qu'on était
toujours dans une espèce de guerre de
tranchées un coup c'était sur le voile
que c'était sur la burqa après c'était
sursis après c'était sur cette serment
ce qui effectivement la frapper puisque
d'un seul coup c'est vrai que ça vaut la
peine de réfléchir comme ça c'est à dire
quelle serait la politique hamon
il se trouve que comme la politique à
mon n'avait pas été réfléchie mon
rapport est sorti en décembre les
attentes en janvier donc ce qui était
mon ma réflexion a - devient une
réflexion sur l'après
pourquoi j'insiste là dessus parce que
justement mon sujet n'est pas comment
est ce qu'on fait redescendre sur terre
un transfèrement c'est à dire comment
est ce qu'on va faire redescendre et
frères kohail chiffres il était encore
vivant pour les ramener c'est pas par
des cours d'instruction civique et
coulibaly c'est sûr qu'on aurait pu
faire tous les cours d'instruction
civique on lui a même permis de
rencontrer le président la république
c'est pas ça qui l'a arrêté c'est donc
il ya une véritable problème qui est un
problème de rapport de la société
française avec sa composante musulmane
avec son organisation administrative et
avec sa politique extérieure et donc ces
trois volets là qui m'ont intéressé
c'est à dire où vont chercher pourquoi
ces types sont arrivés à cet état de
violences qu'est ce qui les a amené
jusque là évidemment vous avez
l'interface c'est à dire qu'est ce qui
se passe sur les sites jihadistes etc
etc et donc mon propos n'est pas de dire
les services de renseignement devrait
faire ci la police devrait faire ça etc
mais mon propos c'est de dire qu'est ce
que les politiques doivent faire
bon je vais vous citer des exemples qui
peut-être vous éclaireront mieux que mon
propos
tous les grands pays occidentaux
aujourd'hui ont une politique de contre
radicalisation enfin surtout les
européens et les américains c'est pas
leur problème
en général ces politiques sonné après un
choc traumatique attentats de londres
dans bretagne caricatures de mahomet au
danemark mort de théo van gogh en
hollande à ce moment là les politiques
ont été interpellées et ils ont réagi
intelligemment en se disant finalement
notre modèle est en difficulté notre
modèle d'intégration est en difficulté
donc il faut réfléchir sur la manière de
se comporter pour que on contribue tous
ensemble la déradicalisation à la contre
la dynamisation
alors ça s'est traduit par trois choses
première chose un discours public c'est
à dire il désigne la cible ce que la
politique française n'a jamais fait un
rappelez-vous le mali c'était le
terrorisme international la rca stéréo
notation a fait il est partout théorie
intéressante ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
arrêter tous les bases que tous les
corses c'est pas le sujet voyez donc on
dit pas quelle est la cible
alors qu'en grande-bretagne en hollande
espère ils ont désigné pourquoi elle
cette désignation parce que la
désignation permet de faire comprendre à
la communauté musulmane dans son
ensemble que ce n'est pas elle qui est
visée dans sa totalité c'est une partie
d'entre elles dont on dénonce les
pratiques les idéologies et c'est
extrêmement important pour éviter l'
espèce de stigmatisation inconsciente
dans lesquelles tout musulman
aujourd'hui est en droit de se sentir au
delà du discours public une organisation
une organisation qui en général s'appuie
sur les collectivités locales pourquoi
parce que le type qui sait le mieux ce
qui se passe dans sa commune c'est pas
le préfet c'est le maire le maire il a
les travailleurs sociaux là la police
municipale il a le bureau d'être social
et le bureau d'aidé éducative etc et
donc il connaît le contact avec l'imam
hilal contact avec l'association
musulmane locale
ce réseau là est un réseau d' alerte et
ensuite le comment dire l'état pourrait
fournir des moyens ça veut dire selon le
cac est signalée si c'est un problème
familial qui va expliquer la conversion
brutale d'un enfant ça peut être un psy
ça peut être un imam ça peut être un
travailleur social et c'est donc l'état
fournisseurs de moyens mais pas l'état
acteurs
ce qui est exactement le contraire de ce
qu'a fait la france
après le printemps dernier quand les
parents d'enfants partis en syrie ont
dit mais nous n'avons pas
d'interlocuteur on a vu notre fils se
radicalise et on l'a vu un jour
disparaître on est allé à la préfecture
au tribunal on est allé au commissariat
de police une personne tout le monde
nous a dit je suis pas responsable et la
réaction immédiate et spécifiquement
française c'est de dire bon c'est à
l'état de s'en occuper donc l'état s'est
dit en france sur les affaires
religieuses et le ministre de
l'intérieur c'est-à-dire ministère de la
police voyez le hiatus il est ridicule
et voilà et donc le bureau des cultes ce
qui est justement l'interlocuteur normal
de toutes les religions se retrouve dans
le même administration que le bureau de
la police enfin que la police et les
services de renseignements intérieurs
donc ça va pas il faut un moment se dire
ce n'est pas un problème de délinquance
ensuite on a de confier l'organisation
et la coordination à un comité qui
s'appelle comité interministériel de
prévention de la délinquance
et on s'est appuyé sur le réseau des
préfectures donc on retrouve tous les
tropiques français c'est à l'état de
faire ce qui à mon avis est une erreur
si est au réseau public de s'en occuper
ce qui est une erreur donc le vous voyez
pourquoi je me situe en amont et
parallèlement à ça on voit on voit par
exemple le qatar l'arabie saoudite faire
exactement
comme certaines organisations
humanitaires avec un drapeau vert
fournir des crédits fournir des
associations de l'argent le fond ce que
vous dites mais dans l'autre sens c'est
byzance une politique locale ils ont de
l'argent qui arrive localement pour des
projets nico ce qui permet aux gens
d'acquérir certaines théories et de se
radicaliser qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors en france pourquoi en france on ne
suit pas les capitaux et pourquoi en
france on tolère des capitaux de ce type
la provenance de la vision la plus
rigoriste de l'islam c'est-à-dire
l'arabie saoudite et et derrière
derrière on a une relation qui est
complètement schizophrénique
alors alors si vous voulez sur la
question de la désignation de la cible
je crois qu'effectivement il faut
revenir sur un certain nombre d'épisodes
historiques qui sont extrêmement
importants
historiquement l'islam politique c'est
plutôt les frères musulmans début du 20e
siècle hassan al banna etc
même si déjà il y avait une espèce de
légitimation du jazz à vian ce peu
importe on est dans une époque où ça
dure ans étaient surtout tournés contre
les pouvoirs locaux contre moubarak est
sévèrement
les frères musulmans font une erreur
majeure qui est en particulier de ceux
solidarité avec saddam hussein quand il
ya la guerre du koweït ce qui pour les
saoudiens et le mans dire le l'état de
l'insurrection absolue
deuxième remarque également qui prouve
que si vous voulez notre sueur
insuffisances d'attention quand les les
américains aidés les les moudjahidines
afghans contre les soviétiques toute
l'aide américaine est passée par
l'intermédiaire de l'arabie saoudite et
par l'intermédiaire des services de
renseignements pakistanais
on ne regardait pas à ces messages le
signaler mais personne ne voulait y
accorder d'importance que toute cette
aide allait plutôt aux partis les plus
radicaux des
des moudjahidines afghans que le boudine
ac matière c'est là que massoud les
alliés si donnez donnez l'argent aux
plus radicaux absolument
systématiquement il était mieux dotés ce
qui évidemment sur leur terrain de
l'ordre sur le terrain lors d'un
avantage de cette 1re et 2e aspects sur
lesquels on sait pas non plus attardé
c'est que les saoudiens ont mis comme
condition que toute l'école doctrinal
dominante au pakistan qu'il est un défi
qui était plutôt une disons pas
tolérante mais enfin disons plus ouverte
bascule dans l'emballage qui est
l'idéologie dominante de l'arabie
saoudite et on a vu dix ans plus tard
les talibans sur le terrain c'est-à-dire
les étudiants en théologie et donc ce
sous produit qu'on croyait est une
espèce d'excroissances un abcès au
savait pas trop vite non c'est le
résultat d'une stratégie qui est une
stratégie dans laquelle on raisonnait en
binaire les ennemis de nos ennemis sont
nos amis donc l'arabie saoudite et en
contre l'urss c'est un ami or en fait
l'arabie saoudite avait sa propre
stratégie et même remarque à propos de
ce que vous dites c'est à dire à partir
des années 80 80 90 les saoudiens
considérant qu' il faut fournir des
imams dans les mosquées de france
puisque le gouvernement français se
refuser à prendre en compte cette
variable a diffusé un peu partout en
afrique en france dans les pays
occidentaux
ces imams wahhabite en l'occurrence
salafistes s'il faut les aigles est
nommé par leur nom et on a laissé faire
complètement la seule première réaction
ça a été en fait sarkozy un beau jour
interdisant un imam invités pour le
sommet du bourget pour la rencontre
annuelle du projet d'entrée mais tout
simplement parce que quand on regardait
le site de ce type s'était du
l'antisémitisme le plus brutal et le
plus commun d'erreurs sans dissimulation
aucune et c'est ça qui lui a permis
d'interdire la venue de ce type donc ce
que vous dites c'est aussi comment
est-ce qu'un moment en déclinant
politique intérieure des barrages qu'on
ne veut pas prendre un politique
extérieure ce qui est quand même une
question importante est donc aujourd'hui
désigné la cible c'est désigner ce
qu'est le salafisme c'est à dire c'est
une idéologie totalitaire comme on en a
connu plein au xxème siècle simplement
celle là elle n'est pas née chez nous
elle est née en arabie saoudite et quand
on si vous voulez si on veut défendre
l'islam comme religion de paix de
tolérance vaut mieux pas avoir l'arabie
saoudite dans son camp
que si l'arabie saoudite est dans le
camp américain quant à oui d'accord avec
vous mais vous voyez donc ce hiatus le
hiatus le plus évident est dans la
guerre en irak on va combattre l'état
islamique parce que il décapite il coupe
les mains des voleurs il opprime les
femmes est il interdit les autres
religions pour aller défendre l'arabie
saoudite qui décapite les mains des
voleurs qui opprime les femmes et qui
interdit de notre religion on prend on
pourra faire une autre émission sur le
sujet lourde et on pourra débattre de ce
qui se passe un petit peu dans le
collier de perles le chapelet d'îles où
il ya la sécurisation américaine qui
commence bien à dire oui
l'énergétique chinoise pour en discuter
j'ai une question concernant le après on
voit on voit notre gouvernement on voit
bernard cazeneuve
voilà le président de la république
demandé des solutions et dans ces
solutions on a vu des marquis
le patriot act à la française
alors je fais un petit rappel pour
nos auditeurs le patriot act avec toutes
les conséquences que ça pue avant aux
états unis sur les libertés publiques et
sur le déploiement dation alliance donc
maintenant on voit un patriot act à la
française on voit une surveillance sur
internet qui devient d'un copier coller
de ce qui se passe aux etats-unis et m'a
clairement l'export du patriot act
américain sur le territoire européen
qu'est ce que vous en pensez la
surveillance d'internet est ce que ça
fait partie des politiques de contrats
radicalisation est ce que c est ce que
c'est légitime est-ce que nous lalala
simple pub nous allons pas avoir des
dommages collatéraux de cette politique
court termiste qui réagit d'une façon
symptomatique
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
d'abord je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur le fait qu' une politique
de sécurité intérieure et culturellement
extrêmement différente selon les grandes
démocraties
les britanniques considéré pendant
longtemps que d'avoir une carte
d'identité était une intrusion dans la
prague acier dans la vie privée bon et
où les amis américains pareil on sait
rexel le permis de conduire délivré par
chacun des états qui est la pièce
d'identité pour nous la carte d'identité
ça fait longtemps qu'on pense pas que
c'est une intrusion dans notre vie
privée et un contrôle de notre sécurité
al'inverse les britanniques avaient
installé des caméras presque dans tous
les rues de londres alors que nous on se
disait les caméras c'est une
surveillance inadmissible et c'est donc
chacun des deux affaires une partie du
rapprochement mais c'est pour vous dire
que parfois les discours rhodia de
droits de l'hommistes s'il voulait se
rendre compte combien ils sont
premiers ils sont très comment dire très
relatif
je vous en cite un exemple parce que
j'aime bien provoquer mais j'étais à
sarajevo peu de temps après la phase
qu'on aura droit de provoquer tout va
bien sûr que j'étais à sarajevo après la
fin de la guerre legault 15 centrales
avaient à reconstituer une espèce
d'administration tenant compte de la
composante celle de la composante
bosniaque de composants droite etc après
une catastrophe humanitaire gigantesque
sortait du bureau dans lequel j'entrais
une association d'homosexuels européen
qui venait demander au président de la
nouvelle république bosniaque quel est
le droit des homosexuels dans l'âme en
bosnie aujourd'hui si ce droit ne
s'adapte pas aux rockets nous nous
opposerons à votre entrée dans l'union
européenne vous imaginez l'espèce de
choc qu'avait ce président se disant
même pas mais j'ai deux cent mille
personnes déplacées pour lesquels il
faut que je fasse des efforts il faut
que je trouve de l'aide humanitaire
internationale il faut que je constitue
une administration faut que je constitue
une force armée d'êta vous voyez le truc
c'est pas que je veuille critiqué le
droit des homosexuels mais il doit y
avoir une hiérarchie qui correspond
quand même sur la question de sécurité
comme sur les questions de droits de
l'homme aux priorités qui sont les
priorités d'urgence donc sur le cas de
la du patriot act il ya deux volets dans
le patriote il ya une partie intérieure
qui évidemment est une partie où je pas
l'impression que les américains se
sentent particulièrement surveillé parce
que sinon c'est aussi un parti il ya
deux choses justement et c'est pour ça
que je voudrais insister là dessus et
puis il ya une partie internationale et
c'est la partie internationale qui était
la plus contraignante parce que par
exemple patriot act imposée que tout le
trafic de containers qui était celui par
lequel on pensait car il vrai toutes les
menaces sur le territoire américain soit
le plus contrôlé ça s'est traduit
comment ça s'est traduit par le fait que
les américains
limiter le nombre de ports
internationaux qui avaient le droit de
charger des conteneurs partant vers les
états unis bon pour la france il ya un
seul port qui a été autorisé à faire ça
c'est le havre et avec présence de
douaniers américains sur place par
exemple deuxième exemple la liste des
passagers avec leurs descriptions à
leurs biographies etc dans des avions
arrivant aux états unis donc la partie
patriot act qui était la plus
scandaleuse c'était les contraintes
qu'ont posée aux autres en particulier
les toutes les données financières
bancaires à chaque fois qu'il y avait un
transfert d'argent vers les états unis
fallait que la banque est étrangère
signal d'où venait l'argent qui était le
propriétaire etc et évidemment il y
avait pas d'échangé d'informations donc
le patriot act a été une formidable
captation se voulait au bénéfice des
états unis d'une grande partie des
données internationales dans le patriot
act à la française je doute qu'on soit
en mesure d'imposer les mêmes
contraintes à nos partenaires donc on
est uniquement sur le volet intérieur
voyez c'est important comme disent les
gens voulaient croustillons c'est le
volet intérieur croustillant
effectivement cela dit si vous le
décomposer par morceau
la surveillance sur internet c'est ce
qu'on fait en matière de lutte contre la
pédophilie par exemple est ce qu'on va
faire je peux vous
vous y connaissez courant lutte sur
internet en termes de pédophilie parce
qu'à vrai dire nous sommes une chaîne de
bakker et et les pédophiles ou les
tracas longueur de journée et de l'uni
et on les trouve surtout 100 onces et
d'accusations dans le vent on les trouve
surtout dans des milieux où il ya de
l'argent où il ya du réseau et quand on
essaye un petit peu de les sortir du
bois on a beaucoup de bouquié qui se
lève donc la traction internet
concernant le deep packet inspection
tout ce qui ce genre de mesures
non mes fans et moi je me place sur le
plan législatif quand c'est pas sur
l'efficacité du dispositif le fait qu'on
surveille internet comme d'ailleurs en
phase d abus de comment dire de droit de
la presse après la loi 10 880 les
adaptations qu'on a fait successivement
etc moi je n'ai pas le sentiment si vous
êtes nouveau libertés sont menacées
quand on prend des mesures contre le
racisme contre l'incitation à la haine
raciale etc sur internet ce média que
vous connaissez mieux que moi mais c'est
un média sur lequel on peut imaginer
en tout cas ne borné par un certain
nombre de pratiques législatives ensuite
que ces pratiques soient efficaces
applicable et terrasse ça si je sais ce
que vous pensez du fait que ce soit pas
contrôlé par un juge à bagdad va pas
parler du dispositif législatif qui
n'est pas encore adoptée mais vous voyez
que sur les écoutes alors là doivent dès
lors blême convoi de programmation
militaire
est passé l'article 20 est passé
on en est à faire de l'accumulation data
de personnes avec des logiciels
prédictive derrière vous en tant que
citoyen qu'est ce que ça peut vous faire
ça vous interpelle si je vous dis par
exemple pour deux euros cinquante j'ai
accès chez carte électorale et sur mon
fichier carte électorale je sais le lieu
de naissance c'est à dire que je suis
capable de localiser par exemple tous
les marocains dommage il est d'ailleurs
tous les marocains qui gagnent de
l'argent puisque les la communauté c'est
à dire que si je vois lieu de naissance
marrakech dans le beau quartier de ma
ville je sais que ce marocain la soie et
à faire un peu plus d'argent que les
autres si du jour au lendemain je veux
faire la même chose sur les juifs sur
les homosexuels sur les noirs sur les
gens à cheveux blancs avec une cravate
rouge qui se mouche je le fais en 48
heures grand maximum je dirais 24 vous
qu'est ce que ça peut oui mais est-ce
que c'est internet lui-même ou est ce
que c'est la loi
comme fer que s'apprêtent à voter
assemblée nationale qui permet ça c'est
ça ma question est ce que c'est l'outil
ou le vecteur ça oui c'est ça la
question que internet soit aujourd'hui
une formidable outil de pénétration dans
la vie privée des gens parce que en
recoupant un certain nombre de filles
qui ne sont pas tous d'origine étatique
si vous avez cette possibilité d'accès
c'est une question qui vous concerne
autant que le législateur alors vous en
tant que citoyen ouais qu'est ce que
vous pensez de donner des lames de
rasoir à un singe c'est à dire que la la
la situation économique les tensions
économiques sont très importantes
les gouvernements changent mais les
outils restent des outils vous parlez
des outils législatifs les outils
législatifs non mais justement le débat
aujourd'hui il est sur l'adaptation de
l'outil législatif
bon donc ça c'est un point pendant un
mois ce qui m'intéresse plus sur les
questions stratégiques c'est comme en l1
pendant comment est-ce que aujourd'hui
on va se plaindre du fait qu'il ya une
ingérence informatique des chinois ou
des nord coréens alors qu'on a révélé
avec la féra singe que le plus
formidable ces instruments d'écouté de
pénétration informatique étaient
américains c'est-à-dire notre principal
allié donc ma question à moi en tant que
stratégiste c'est de me dire comment est
ce que fait ce fait un moment éteindre
un débat qui lui paraît essentielle pour
en faire naître un autre qui me paraît
beaucoup moins important donc votre
question c'est effectivement ça c'est
aujourd'hui qui est en mesure de
pratiquer certaines régulations
démocratique sur internet est ce que
c'est le législateur ou est ce que c'est
les hackers on l'a bien vu avec
anonymous que c'est plutôt les hackers
ça c'est quand même un défi politique
formidable on voit bien qu'avec assange
aujourd'hui assagi le plus persécutés
comme l'était abou qatada ou abu hamza
qui étaient les générateurs de landau
distance d'ailleurs commenté un problème
démocratique on est con et une
surveillance sur un change vraiment
la chaussette
les frères kwasi et été laissés dans la
nature non c'est à dire que là pour pour
un changement la surveillance est devenu
physique c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on
empêche simplement de sortir ce qui est
quand même ce qui est intéressant c'est
que on peu
moyen un sujet qui m'a beaucoup amusé
c'est pourquoi est ce qu'on qualifie
différemment les mêmes faits bon si vous
voulez un type est enlevé en colombie
vous demande de rançon c'est une prise
d'un kidnapping il est enlevé en irak
c'est une prise d'otages il est détenu à
guantanamo c'est un délit de droit
commun souvenirs et les mêmes laisser le
même situation il n'y a pas grande
avocat il a pas leurs devoirs sa famille
le pen n'a pas le droit de passer devant
un juge etc or on qualifie pas les mêmes
choses des mêmes termes ça c'est un truc
extrêmement pendant or assange c'est ça
qui me paraît le plus extraordinaire
c'est que sans le dire exactement on
sent qu'il ya une déstabilisation
majeure de systèmes de surveillance dans
les pays démocratiques parce que il a
révélé quelque chose qui était beaucoup
plus important que ce que propager les
émirs du londonistan et ça c'est quand
même extraordinaire qu'il n'y ait pas
une mobilisation pour défendre assange
en disant mais attendait que la suède
s'engage à ne pas l'extrader vers les
états unis puisque ces sacs dont il a
peur parce qu'une fois qu'il sera aux
états unis sera condamné à cent trente
cinq ans de prison il ya peu de chances
qu'ils sortent effectivement ou de six
cent trente cinq ans de prison
c'est ça qui est le plus extraordinaire
c'est à dire que des états démocratiques
aujourd'hui nous ne pose pas à
l'extradition d'assange par exemple les
deux poids deux mesures ah oui exemple
caractéristique les types du londonistan
tous ces émirs qui ont généré les
attentats de 2004
refusé de les extrader vers leur pays
d'origine le yémen la jordanie et c'est
parce qu'ils disaient qu'ils risquaient
la peine de mort formidables vont
coopérer avec les états unis qui
appliquent la peine de mort
d'accord enfin sorte d' erreur de ma
part en tout cas ce que j'ai vu donc
vous voyez bien comment on fait deux
poids deux mesures le comment il
s'appelait rachid ramda qu'on a demandé
en angleterre d'extrader à la suite des
attentats de 94
dans les rues de paris les anglais
pendant dix ans ont expliqué que c'était
compliqué qu'il fallait saisir la haute
cour etc puis évidemment les avocats de
ramda a utilisé toutes les ressources de
droit la dernière des refus
d'extradition était expliquée par le
fait qu'ils risquaient d'être torturés
dans les commissariats français mes
souvenirs j'ai jamais entendu la justice
britannique dire assange ils risquent
d'être torturés aux états unis donc on
est vraiment dans un système de deux
poids deux mesures et pourquoi est ce qu
assange est un personnage aussi comment
dire
inquiétant c'est parce qu'ils révèlent
des pratiques qui sont les pratiques
également existant également dans les
états démocratiques où on se refuse à
démontrer que les états unis puis c'est
un risque voire une menace pour les
autres pays occidentaux
rivalité économique
connaissances sur les leaders politiques
qui l'écoutent de angela merkel c'est
quand même pas mal à la pression sur la
vie sexuelle d'angela merkel qui
attention de surveiller c'est évidemment
les processus décisionnels c'est ce qui
se passe en europe la commission
européenne etc donc il y avait dans le
champ de l'ecoute la totalité des moyens
d'une maîtrise du monde
qui a ouvert le débat
l'allemagne parce qu'on écoutait son
chancelier coup c'est un manque de
courage c'est quoi c'est une démission
c'est c'est la pensée c'est le pouvoir
de la non décision c'est quoi je sais
pas je sais pas franchement je ne sais
pas mais c'est vrai que c'est une
veulerie qui est quand même inadmissible
admissible c'est le terme la veulerie
couardise et donc puisqu'on a tous ces
moyens là
je puisse qu'on a tous ces moyens là on
peut donc finalement avoir une attitude
ici on peut qu'on fait pas
au niveau de la sémiologie qu'est-ce que
ça indique
je pense que c'est une réflexion
stratégique à très court terme qui est
on ne se fâche pas avec le grand allié
c'est de la stratégie à très court terme
moi je me suis beaucoup intéressé par
exemple à la façon dont si vous voulez
le général de gaulle
penser sa stratégie diplomatique de
rupture c'est à dire un beau jour il y à
ses collaborateurs je vais reconnaître
la chine populaire passait bien
qu'autour de lui tout le monde a dit
raymond général je n'y pensais pas chine
populaire les américains etc il a dit on
va se retirer de l'otan je pensais bien
qu'autour de lui les gens lui ont dit à
ma fille laura foulée fait rapatrier
leurs de la france et voilà donc si vous
voulez vous avez autour de vous un
certain nombre de gens il faut connaître
la sociologie des cabinets si vous
voulez un cabinet qui entoure un
ministre c'est une cour quand tu auras
roi dès courts est composée de partisans
bon et donc vous avez quand vous avez
autour de vous des gens qui toute leur
vie ils disent ah oui monsieur le
ministre les résidents faim pendant les
deux ans vous êtes au pouvoir oui
monsieur mise des raisons monsieur nice
quelle bonne idée monsieur le ministre
il ya mon vous déconnecter que la
réalité la grandeur de de gaulle c'était
d'avoir toujours cette réalité avec l'a7
ce contact avec la réalité de la
géopolitique du monde
aujourd'hui à l'oreille je sais qu'il
avait payé de sa personne va même un bon
aujourd'hui on est dans une génération à
laquelle j'appartiens ou si vous voulez
la connaissance du monde quand on est
dans les hautes sphères de décision
c'est très simple vous arrivez dans un
pays étranger la voiture de
l'ambassadeur vous attend vous emmène à
l'ambassade à l'ambassade vous avez un
déjeuner où l'ambassadeur vous explique
le pays en deux heures ensuite vous avez
vos entretiens officiels où vous voyez
vos homologues qui évidemment vous
disent tout le monde accorde beaucoup
d'importance à la position de la france
sur le sujet qui nous préoccupe et c'est
à quelle est votre analyse sur le soir
vous avez un dîner officiel
le lendemain vous avez à nouveau des
contacts avec votre vos homologues et
puis vous remontez va bien alors peu de
sang frais règne et tapage sur les
poules oui c'est ça mais c'est surtout
qu'elle contacte avez vous imaginez vous
que vous alliez en israël en allant à
tel aviv seulement voyez ce que veut
dire et vous allez à new delhi en étant
cadets vous allez en même temps qu'à
tout gagne ou délit vous allez aux états
unis en allant qu'à washington
je sens d'ailleurs aux états unis qui se
traduit sur ticulier charles iv qu'on
peut buter jean noir dans la rue je fais
juste ouvrir est ce la chaîne de
commandement au niveau des services de
renseignement il ya bien des honorables
contributeurs qui sont sur un terrain
qu'il faut remonter l'information je
prends par exemple les révolutions
arabes veulent marier deux
officines d'intelligence économique
pas officiels disent merci d'excuser
mois passé le qualificatif dégradant
c'était pas le fond la chanson désolé
excusez moi
il ya des gens de terrain qui font
remonter l'info ou des gens qui sont
connectés avec la population des gens
qui se baladent kiki qui vont serrer des
pognes de berger pour savoir ce qui se
passe il a eu des mecs passé avec des
kalachnikov il ya des gens qui font ça
il ya des gens qui font remonter
l'information ces gens là commence à
ranger un peu lent france et dire que la
chaîne de commandement la remonter
l'information est pas respectée qu'est
ce que vous en pensez tous à côté je
vais vous raconter un épisode comme a
relaté parce que je me suis beaucoup
intéressé à la raison comment dire au
début de la relation franco iranienne
après la révolution de 79 rappelez-vous
khomeiny étant en france il revient dans
un avion d'air france il s'était rendu
leurs manifestations et des 3 millions
d'iraniens dans la rue c'était là il
était qui applaudissent avec le
commandant de bord qui fait descendre au
ministère donc une espèce d'histoire
d'amour où tous les jours devant
l'ambassade de france il y avait des
glaïeuls blanc était avant et puis on
peu de moi on se retrouve aux côtés de
saddam hussein et on est le principal
fournisseur de saddam hussein dont
qu'est ce qui s'est passé entre les deux
et en discutant avec quelqu'un qui était
à ce moment là dans les cabinets
ministériels
il m'a dit écoute moi je suis arrivé en
iran 78 quelque chose comme ça au 119
mon ambassadeur quitter son poste et le
chef de poste dgse quitter son poste
l'ambassadeur le fait son testament
alors qu'il fait sa lettre ci voulait
dans lesquelles ils expliquent les
conclusions qu'il tire de son séjour en
iran et dans lesquels il dit le shah
d'iran ma part et hatton ces
visionnaires chefs d'état visionnaire
auquel le plus bel avenir et promis et
ses deux mois après la révolution
le chef de poste dgse dit
l'iran c'est un pays dans lequel il ya 1
% de francophones c'est ce qu'on voit
tout le temps il ya 2 % d'anglophones
c'est ce qu'on voit mais un peu moi et
97 % de personnes aux fautes qu'on ne
voit jamais qu'est ce qui se passe après
c'est là que c'est intéressant pour
répondre à votre question il se fait
allumer par le quai d'orsay qui lui dit
ce n'est pas la ligne officielle de la
diplomatie française il se fait allumer
par sa propre administration 10 en
double pas que notre mission est de
fournir du renseignement brut vous voyez
pourquoi je cite l'exemple c'est parce
que la capacité d'un système à prendre
en compte quelque chose qui est une
rupture est extrêmement difficile vous
allez expliquer à votre ministre
monsieur le ministre savait on a besoin
de se planter complètement
soit c'est vous qui changeait de
l'affectation ça vous disparaissez du
cabinet soit votre ministre est
intelligent il s'arrête il écoute
on fait quoi mais je veux dire et donc
vous avez les deux types de scénarios
faut quand même se rendre compte que si
vous voulez il ya un facteur que jamais
les politologues n'utilise dans
l'explication du monde c'est la bêtise
des individus
exemples vécus pour que vous compreniez
la chose
génocide au rwanda le génocide éclate
l'ambassadeur sur place parle de rumeurs
on a vu la suite toujours est il que on
se trouve dans une situation
internationale où les américains ne
voulaient plus intervenir vous savez la
somalie la sphère faucon noir et c'est
donc clinton ferme les yeux complètement
les autres pays occidentaux disent nous
l'afrique ces panneaux etc et la france
qui avait été un des pays qui avait le
plus soutenu habyarimana
comme c'est une période de colloques de
collaboration de colonne n'ont pas de
collaboration de comment on appelle
quand il ya un gouvernement de gauche et
puis ils n'ont aucun droit si vite et
rendre aux habitations pendant
il se trouve par chance que c'est un
gouvernement de cohabitation c'est à
dire que mitterrand qui était le plus
africaniste il voulait des soutes un des
soutiens d'abord être d'habyarimana se
trouve contesté par balladur par juppé
qui veulent absolument empêcher le
génocide de se faire renvoyer le la
fracture interne au gouvernement
français finalement
juppé et balladur l'emportent et donc on
met l'opération turquoise en place
l'opération turquoise consistait 1 a
essayé de faire des zones sécurisées
pour que les tutsis reste encore sur
place puissent être protégées je le sais
parce que j'ai participé à la conception
on se trouve un dimanche après midi dans
le bureau du directeur de cabinet le
bureau du directeur cabinet s'est testé
léotard à l'époque
que des chefs avec la caractéristique
générale des chefs c'est à dire qu'il
n'avait jamais mis les pieds au rwanda
puisque évidemment leur carrière était
parisienne quand même pas demander aux
gens en plus d'être sur le terrain voir
le chef de cabinet il son père combien
ces gens là pardon ils sont payés
combien c'est pas trés payer
l'administration 5000 6000 voix c'est le
rouble 5,6 me
non je pense pas je pense ça doit être
beaucoup moins que ça pour un directeur
d'administration centrale ça doit être
de 15 100 euros par mois choix d'accord
je partage parce vous donne un chiffre
comme ça mais bon attendez laissez moi
réfléchir ça ferait quoi ça ferait vingt
mille par an noncé peut-être sous
laquelle je vous donnerai les chiffres
mais on n'est pas dans les tarifs du
prix vert est alors donc le chef du
cabinet militaire explique le
déploiement des forces françaises qui
doivent arriver sur place pour sécuriser
des zones
alors qu'un raisonnement assez simple
qui est une technique militaire et 10 à
goma au zaïre ya une plate forme
aérienne donc on va se mettre là et on
va déployer dans le nord du rwanda parce
que c'est plus simple en terme de
communication de déploiement des troupes
et c'est la seule personne qui était
dans la réunion et qui n'avait aucune
raison d'y être
c'était la seule personne qui
connaissait le rwanda c'est un
universitaire que d'un type du cabinet
intelligent qui est en l'occurrence jean
christophe rufin avait amené dans la
réunion
donc ce type il écoute tout ça personne
n'avait grand chose à dire parce que
personne n'était capable de critiquer de
la technicité militaire et lui lève le
doigt et d'écouté excusez moi mais si
vous vous mettez au nord du rwanda
aujourd'hui à plus de tutsi au rwanda
parce qu'ils ont tous été massacrés ils
se sont réfugiés dans les collines du
sud donc si vous mettez au nord vous
pourrez toujours expliqué que vous êtes
là pour sauver des soucis mais aucun des
belligérants de croire à ce que vous
êtes en train d'expliquer puisque ils le
savent et donc ils vont penser qu'une
fois de plus les français intervienne
parce que ils viennent essayer de sauver
le régime qu'ils ont toujours soutenu le
régime des hutus ce type n'aurait pas
été dans la salle tout le monde aurait
donné d'explication qui va nous donner
parce qu'on suppose toujours que les
décideurs sont rationnels on va pas
expliquer que les gens ne connaissent
pas le pays qui donc vont prendre une
décision aussi importante en termes
humains mais simplement par bêtise et
c'est assez terrible quand vous êtes
politologue vous souhaitez vous devez
prendre en compte la bêtise des gens ça
veut dire qu'une partie de votre sueur
difficile et a disparu alors et c'est
pourtant un élément important de deux
dernières questions
c'est justement une des choses sur le
rebond d'hier est-ce que c'est par la
même bêtise en fait que vous pourriez
expliqué une sorte d'idéologie à
ollières qui nous convainc qui continue
de nous emmener dans des guerres qui ne
sont pas du tout
c'est à dire d'un intérêt quelconque
pour la france et l'europe en général
bon je vais être plus polie que vous
disons que c'est une absence de culture
internationale on le dit comme ça mais
en gros la question est tout à fait
légitime prenons le cas de notre
président aujourd'hui sa culture
internationale s'était d'appartenir à
l'international d'aller à des réunions
et à l'internationale socialiste où il y
avait moubarak et ben ali bon c'est tout
je vous ai fait le tableau rapidement et
donc cette absence de culture
internationale s'est en particulier de
se dire qu'un pays c'est une culture une
espèce de cohésion sociale rapport à la
guerre etc qui fait qu' on peut ne pas
s'interroger on peut s'interroger sur la
nécessité d'utiliser moi d'utiliser des
moyens armés deuxième caractéristique
qui est un peu la conséquence du tableau
que j'ai dit c'est tout à l'heure il
n'ya pas d'ennemis stratégique
aujourd'hui est donc le véritable
critère de décision c'est l'opinion
publique intérieure si vous avez un
intellectuel médiatique qui vous fait un
pari un article du genre nous sommes
tous des ukrainiens où nous sommes tous
des libyens oui le politique qui vit le
journal le matin en arrivant et il se
dit ciel diable que dois-je faire voyez
ce que je veux dire c'est pas un
processus rationnel c'est devenu un
processus de comment dire de
géopolitique de l'émotion
le conflit le plus meurtrier depuis la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale c'est
le conflit du congo 25000 2 million et
demi de morts vingt-cinq mille enfants
soldats esclaves sexuelles etc qui parle
des concours du congo c'est trop
compliqué c'est des noirs on sait pas le
m23 qui sait que vous voyez ce que je
veux dire si l'on veut à la gravité de
la crise qui motive la chose c'est la
gravité médiatique de la crise et c'est
ça qui est dramatique
et donc au lieu d'avoir une espèce de
c'est là sa grandeur de de gaulle qui
pouvaient un moment se dire mais la
crise il faut en tenir compte de ces
caractéristiques politiques avant de
décider là on décide en fonction de ce
que l'opinion publique va penser de ce
que vous êtes en train de faire est ce
que vous pourriez que nous devrions
rester dans l'otan
il y avait un large débat news avait
justement fait sortir du machin moi ce
qui me qualifier de machin ben si vous
voulez vous êtes en passe et retourner
si vous voulez l'histoire de l'otan est
assez intéressante parce que quand en 91
donc urss décide de dissoudre 89 décide
de dissoudre le pacte de varsovie
les occidentaux avait implicitement
accepter la dissolution de l'otan
ça c'est pas fait quand vous avez pu le
constater et puis surtout les russes
avaient mis comme condition qu'
effectivement qui est pas d'extension de
l'otan vers l'est vous avez vu la suite
donc on est dans un système encore une
fois qu'il ne tient pas compte du tout
de ce que pense l'autre et donc on va le
trouver comme on va le considéré comme
menaçant désagréable agressif et cetera
sans se demander si on a nous même
généré cette agression cette méchanceté
cette réaction c'est ça le processus
intellectuel pourquoi parce qu'on a
inventé un truc formidable dans les
années dont les années 50 10 ans qui
s'appelle l'opinion publique
internationale c'est formidable comme
idée parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on parle
on parle au nom de l'opinion publique
internationale
les pays qui ont voté la résolution
d'interdiction aérienne sur la libye
c'est 9 % de la population mondiale 9%
les autres se sont abstenus ou ont voté
contre mais ces 9 % c'est l'opinion
publique internationale et donc à chaque
fois on se légitime si vous voulez en
expliquant que nous sommes là parce que
nous sommes le chevalier blanc porteur
de toutes les valeurs universelles
espère c'est ça le processus
intellectuel j'ai donc l'absence de
culture internationale c'est ça est ce
que nous devrions écrire résumé
l'opinion internationale par
par une main sa forme de gens on va dire
bercé par le jeu où il joue bien du
cheval blanc du gentil américain qui
vient sauver la petite fille
avec un ce même système de valeurs
projeté donc c'est on va dire 9% pour
être un peu vulgaire 9% de bobos de
l'opinion internationale qui vote ayant
un pouvoir d'achat pouvoir permettre de
faire réélire x ou y dirigeant ce que c
est ce que c'est le bras armé de nos
politiques cette fameuse opinion
internationale qu'on peut manipuler
corps et âme on les abreuvant soit de
propos anxiogènes
soient de bons sentiments dominent ce
sentiment écoutez en tout cas ça pose
une question qui mériterait une analyse
plus approfondie c'est à dire
qu'effectivement maintenant mais vous
avez raison de le formuler un fan de vue
de formuler la question
moi je suis obligé de constater on le
voit bien que l'on retrouve le même
personnage bhl qui déclenché la guerre
en libye et puis qui ensuite ramène les
gens du le nouveau pouvoir ukrainien
dans le nouveau président au nouveau
président donc qu'il ya quelque chose
qui quand même mérite qu'on s'interroge
sur mais qui fait la notoriété de ces
individus alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est que vous avez chez un certain
nombre d'intellectuels des positions de
pouvoir c'est à dire quand vous avez un
même individu qui est au conseil de
surveillance de la cet qui est au comité
des lecteurs du monde et cetera vous
avez vu les nouveaux chiens de garde oui
oui je l' ai vu que je vous réponds ça
j'ai trouvé ça très bien je voulais
revenir on constate d'ailleurs sur les
plateaux télé il recommandé ah bah oui
mais j'ai vu j'ai trouvé ça est ce que
vous connaissez naomi klein samedi
quelque chose la stratégie du choc je
connais pas ça tient je conseille
vivement et je vous propose qu'on
refasse une émission sur ce concept une
dernière question juste pour terminer
les gens voient très jugé dans la
stratégie de séduction que vous évoquez
c'est à dire le rapport aux états unis
j'ai deux ou trois choses pour que vos
auditeurs retiennent ces choses en tête
le rapport à la guerre les américains
ont perdu moins de monde dans tous les
conflits du xxème siècle de mort pour
des raisons de détention d'armes à
l'intérieur des états unis
quand vous avez d'un côté 20 millions de
morts en russie vous avez moins d'un
million de morts aux etats unis le
rapport à la guerre n'est pas le même
parce que vous l'avez jamais phocéen
3h45 oui et non toutes les guerres du xx
e siècle toute la gamme y compris le
vietnam et complète après 40
il ya eu à peu près cent
quatre-vingt-dix mille morts la seconde
guerre mondiale america il ya eu 160
morts belge combien de mots russes et 20
millions trésor et donc vous avez
quelque chose qui est quelque chose
d'assez fascinant c'est à dire quand la
guerre mais s'est jamais passé sur votre
territoire que vous ne savez pas ce avec
une ville bombardée vous savez pas ce
que c'est gai tickets de rationnement
vous savez pas ce que c'est que de faire
des queues à des points d'eau et que
votre guerre a toujours été médiatisé
par hollywood votre rapport à la guerre
et à la décision de l'intervention armée
est complètement différent de celui des
russes bon j'écoutais une interview de
jean gabin vous savez que son gamin
était à l'époque à hollywood et ans que
la france perd la guerre et que
finalement il décide de rejoindre
londres pour s'engager dans les forces
françaises libres
il a fait discrètement il s'en est pas
vanté il est parti il est allé au
consulat de grande bretagne il a demandé
à partir vers londres il se trouve dans
un bateau de ses convois vous savez de
l'atlantique nord qui était sous le feu
des sous marins des torpilles des
sous-marins sont le fait des bombardiers
lorient d'action allemands etc et serrer
les fesses parce qu'il avait peur comme
ce n'était pas possible il avait vu
juste avant de partir un film sur ces
convois de l'atlantique nord est un des
capitaines de ces bateaux et elle ferait
bogert et un frigo garde était impérial
dans la tempête évidemment c'est à dire
ça tire de tous les côtés mais il était
là et garder son sang-froid et gamins se
disait mais quel con secondaires tels
france mona et c'est ça la guerre quand
vous l'avez toujours vu à travers le
cinéma vous ne pouvez pas avoir le même
rapport à la guerre ça c'est une faute
maintenant on à jack bauer
alors l'autre aspect c'est celui-là
c'est qu'aujourd'hui chaque semaine vous
avez un super héros américains qui sauve
la planète alors moi je propose est
justement la fabrication de l'ennemi que
nous on a des supers intellectuelle oui
mais à chelles et d'eau fait ou pas
louper ah non non non non jusqu'à
l'échéance et les plans concert c'est le
nouveau concept c'est le nouveau moyen
d'armement moi j'ai proposé qu'on fasse
un jumelage bhl stallone et rend les
envoie en afghanistan avait un jumelage
sur le terme génétique ou non
faire de manipulations génétiques mais
bhl avec les deux articles que j'ai
retrouvé dans le point expliquant
comment il fallait résoudre la crise
afghane et bhl je me serve de cet
argument pour le court que je sois
sciences po
j'ai acheté rambo de rambo 2 c'est le
moment où il revient au vietnam parce
qu'il ya toujours des pilotes américains
emprisonnés par ces de
vietnamiens et serment il y va on va le
chercher lui évidemment et il dit cette
fois on y va pour gagner argument
classique de l'extrême droite si on a
perdu c'est la faute de ces bureaucrates
et ses politiciens et dans le film heat
eu 72 type 72 alors évidemment il était
tout seul je veux dire alors à l'arc au
pistolet à la mitrailleuse à la doucette
du regard non non non non parce que
quand même un moment il se coupe à la
main quand même et donc là il faut que
l'héroïne le soigne mais comme l'héroïne
est une occasion il faut qu'elle meurt
il faut pas qu'ils reviennent mais il ne
faut pas qu'ils ramènent une femme le
bât bon mais imaginez une minute qu'on
fasse un film comme ça sur l'algérie un
mec qui disent on va retourner en
algérie cette fois on y va pour gagner
et qui tuent 72 algérien vous imaginez
le scandale politique que ça ferait en
france et nous on prend ça oui mais
c'est pas grave si un film d'aventurés
voyez le décalage psychologique le
rapport à la violence en particulier le
rapport la violence messieurs d'ailleurs
le héros est américain et évidemment le
héros le bon héros qui est plus musclée
que le mot verront que le que le méchant
allez on va on va terminer l'interview
je vous posais juste deux petites
questions la première ça consiste je
vous cite un mot et vous me dites du tac
au tac à quoi ça vous fait penser le
bahreïn
bahreïn c'est l'exemple même du trou
noir de la réflexion stratégique
occidental est occupé par les sur ayew
gyan qui ont réprimé la majorité de la
population chiite pour rétablir une
monarchie sunnite donc ça fait partie de
ces interventions extérieures de nos
alliés pour lequel entrent dans tomb
arabie saoudite arabie saoudite c'est à
peu près la corée du nord intellectuelle
c'est à dire que c'est le même état
d'esprit
interdiction de tous souhaitent aller en
arabie saoudite pour voir ce que c'est
je veux dire la seule distraction c'est
le sens commercial
je termine juste sur l'arabie saoudite
et donc sur l'arabie saoudite c'est un
fantastique
c'est un fantastique convenir trou noir
encore une fois de la pensée stratégique
aux clientes à achat affaire la salle
non non non achat en france par les
capitaux du qatar
moi ça ne me gêne pas à partir du moment
où on les gère c'est à dire par exemple
quand le qatar avait décidé de faire un
haut fond d'intervention pour les
banlieues françaises appartement le
gouvernement a dit d'accord mais ce sera
du 50-50 et même du 50 plus une voix sur
50 % j'ai rien contre on est en mal de
capital et donc ça ne me gêne pas à
condition qu'ils ont encore une fois ce
soit surveiller gérer et fait dans la
philosophie de la république française
la chair et lassaad ben bachar el-assad
c'est intéressant parce que justement ça
montre combien aujourd'hui il est
difficile de faire du noir et blanc
comme on faisait à l'époque de la guerre
froide parce que tout à coup on se dit
mais lequel des lequel laquelle des
solutions eda pire et quand on ne sait
pas quelle est la solution à pire le
mieux c'est pas intervenir on n'a jamais
réussi à arrêter une guerre civile par
une intervention extérieure militaire
kadhafi kadhafi kadhafi j'avoue que là
aussi on était dans la même situation
personne ne pouvait véritablement
prévoir la décomposition du pays une
fois sa disparition une fois qu'ils
auraient disparu donc il ya eu une
espèce de mèche qui a été allumé on ne
savait pas qu'elle était l'intensité de
l'explosion mais on revient sur quelque
chose qui devrait passer constat qu'il
faut faire aujourd'hui c'est que il faut
cesser de surutiliser l'outil militaire
quand on ne veut pas se donner la peine
d'analyser politiquement john mccain
c'est le fabricant de frites
laurent fabius bat laurent fabius c'est
intéressant parce que c'est une
trajectoire de ces types qui justement
aujourd'hui se font partie des néo
conservateurs arrivés au pouvoir
qui ne se refuse à tout réexamen de sa
propre politique
alors que les américains sont en train
de normaliser leurs relations à l'iran
pour des raisons d'ailleurs qu'on
comprend parce qu'on a besoin des
iraniens pour résoudre la crise en
afghanistan au pakistan liban en syrie
en irak ce qui est quand même pas mal on
a toujours un président qui campe seul
au saut à l'avant du titanic en disant
je suis maître du monde bon problème
c'est que le titanic vous connaissez la
suite de l'histoire
est derrière question si vous aviez
laissé si vous aviez a laissé une
bouteille à la mer sur internet on va
vous rendre immortel aujourd'hui si vous
aviez a laissé une bouteille sur
internet aux jeunes générations les
jeunes générations est ce que vous avez
un conseil à leur donner
quelque chose pour maximiser lors des
france intellectuelle contre la
dialectique de la novlangue
c'est une question extrêmement difficile
parce que il ya déjà eu une première un
premier slogan qui a une extraordinaire
popularité c'était le indignez vous
stéphane hessel moi je leur dirai
travailler étudier regarder apprenez
c'est vraiment la seule protection qu'on
ait aujourd'hui contre cette espèce de
flou des formations immédiate
donnez-vous le temps de réfléchir au
bord de la grande grave oui puis surtout
apprendre apprendre à prendre c'est ça
qui est cette espèce de notre société a
ceci de paradoxal qu'on veut dire mais à
20 ans vous pouvez être milliardaire si
vous donnez footballeurs ou chanteur de
charme vous devenez toutacoo
milliardaire donc si vous voulez il ya
une dégradation de la connaissance
ses trajectoires là sont des
trajectoires incroyablement séduisante
pour des jeunes or on ne pourra pas
jamais faire l'économie de savoir quand
même le jour où on se trouve face à la
difficulté qu'elle pousse surprendre
regarder pendant l'occupation
après l'occupation c'est facile
aujourd'hui de dire il fallait être dans
la résistance mais les gens qui étaient
face à ce problème à 3 ou 9% la populace
qui va à l'église et cette espèce de
distance critique qui faisait quand de
gaulle qui tourne à un type de droite et
voire d'extrême droite à ces
monarchistes au début des cibles que la
france c'était autre chose que bêta et
on a de l'autre côté un petacchi avait
auréolé de sa gloire et serra qui
pouvait séduire la majorité de la
population parce que c'était l'horreur
de la france cette espèce d'examen
individuelles qui fait qu'on se
positionne sur des valeurs après une
connaissance
c'est ça le véritable défi de l'homme
indépendant aujourd'hui
pierre connais ça merci merci à vous
[Musique]
à partir du moment où on autorise les
opérateurs à faire ce qu'ils veulent sur
le réseau en fait on les autorise à
modifier la société où les autorise à
modifier la façon dont les gens
interagissent et de mieux en mieux il ya
de plus en plus de porter besoin non
plus de savoir de taille de plus en plus
de solutions et de plus en plus de
capitaux pour des projets c'est à dire
que ce qui manque à l'heure actuelle
que dans beaucoup de pays ont fait
évoluer quelques institutionnels pour
inclure la société civile dans des bars
et on est très loin de faire ça en
france bon c'est même un peu la terreur
des institutions